do you fight that's impossible yeah so
we have a um in a in a sense we fight
we've never had like we've never punched
punched each other in the face I don't
think we've ever got close I love that
you're saying that with pride like
that's an amazing we've never either did
we well I just want to set the standard
we've never had it's been harder to not
punch you in the face than well that's
because you can't control your emotions
but we at least I have emotions we
haven't had one of those things where
it's like I'm not talking to you I me
maybe like for a day there may be like
okay I'm and I'm not talking to you
today but there's never been like an
extended period of time where it was
like we weren't communicating or we
weren't okay oh we got to work on this
thing we got to shoot this thing where
we would just kind of get through it but
we very rarely let resentment build so I
had to tell too long you're not an old
married couple then yeah there's too
much at stake it's like I mean we we we
don't we're not just staying together
for the children it's like we actually
want to enjoy ourselves yeah but when
you uh disagree and when there is some
friction between
you outside of business or what and may
business may be the thing that starts
that friction you would think it would
be hard to be funny and entertaining or
maybe that adds to it sometimes when
people are like messed up great songs
come to mind you know there's there's
two different levels of this the first
level is can we talk about the second
level first yeah yeah yeah the first was
just easy I'll get it out of the way
yeah I'll give you more the second one
the juicy one I guess okay go ahead the
unj juicy one is just like you just get
so we just get on each other's nerves
and you just need some time apart like
we spent so many hours together for so
many years that it's like okay we're not
going to hang out on the weekends you
know it's like we had to start having
separate weekend lives and then it would
you know we we get better at not being
annoyed with each other and and but that
type of thing will come through but when
you do five shows a week right for
almost 11 years
now fans start to pick up on tension and
they make a lot more of it than it
actually is they're like this is the
year but it is there at times like you
go from like we're having a great time
together to we're we sometimes we'll try
to harness the
frustration into comedy so we'll start
taking more Jabs at each other and it's
just a different tone
but it I think it's still funny but it's
a bit dangerous because it starts to get
a little too true you we might stop
laughing like we might not be laughing
at each other we might be doing
something that someone watching is
laughing at but you can tell oh they're
not making each other laugh today I
think that's a good indicator that
they're a little bit they're annoyed
with each other but that's far from
saying you know I I can't do a show this
week yeah the juicier thing
is the
there's been a couple of times when it's
you know we make fun of like being in
touch with like me me being in touch
with my emotions or him not being and
like that's that's an extreme and that's
not true but there have been times in
the
past like maybe a couple of like maybe
two times over the 11 years that I've
been like if we're not like I don't want
to I don't want to be friends on camera
if we're not if I don't feel like we're
friends off camera and it I would have
this
very I would have a need for us to just
hang out have fun together do something
together and that wasn't just for
somebody else's entertainment but just
for us it's like a method actor I would
have it's like when you show up for a
movie no Howe it's called being an
actual friend but and see my perspective
on that you're so you're on red side on
this a method well when you have to okay
go ahead so we've we've worked this out
but one of the things that we found is
that um I've always thought even from
the early days when we were in a cow
pasture when we were 14 doing a Blood
Oath saying that we were going to create
together one day or create something big
together just we didn't it was ambiguous
we had no idea what it was going to be
but we knew we wanted to create together
when we get together like you know we
had we were in a high school band
together I always saw
us being together like our friendship
was kind of based in the things that we
were going to do together and to create
together so sometimes we'll be hanging
out we'll be watching something and I
can't watch any I can't be entertained
by anything without immediately start
thinking about what are we going to do
like how what does this Inspire us to do
and sometimes to be like don't talk
about work right now and so for me I
don't see it as work right I see what we
do
as my passion and it's the way that I
kind of experience my friendship with
link is the things that we do together
and the things that we create together
but I respect him when he says let's not
talk about work because I do realize
that well it is also business it is also
work and if it just becomes about the
things that we're doing together which
are so externally focused they're
designed to kind of be for somebody else
a lot of times and not just for us that
I have to kind of pull back and be like
okay you know what we'll talk about that
on
Monday
d